i'm 22 months you know off the sauce and
that's
that's part of it alcohol alcohol no
alcohol
and no drugs and no cigarette is a big
part of it
you know that's hard to get off that
stuff isn't that hard was it very
difficult for you to get off that
uh 12 days in the men's central jail
that's all it took
in the men's central jail what what
happened at the jail that you decided i
can't do this anymore
i was sitting there and um the judge had
said
uh i'm gonna give you if you mess up
i'm gonna give you 120 days
and i messed up and i showed up back in
there and i got 120 days
in the men's central jail and um
i was you know people think that it's uh
i don't know i had a friend a gay friend
who said was it erotic
erotic did you see people showering
like mean prisoners i go no
i saw ugly fat people nasty
ugly horrid people and it wasn't funny
and it's like the playground and they
were mean to me
but you know it's what happened after i
got to jail
that made the big difference i i gotta i
did my time
and when i got out i got my first job
and it was on caroline in the city
i remember the show and i had never
worked completely sober
i mean not that i was ever really loaded
at work
but i was either coming off of some
weekend bender or looking forward
anyway i went to my sponsor at the time
and i said listen
i'm i don't know how to work i don't
know what to do
he's okay i'm gonna tell you something
you show up to be of loving service
i so that's a bunch of problem that's
what about hippie i'm gonna
show up
look of loving service what am i sure
with flowers
he said no no no now listen to me i want
you to show up and be of service
to your director this means that you
have your lines
learned this means that it's his project
it's his story
he is the director you as the actor
allowed to bring things
you know on board but you are of service
to a director
you're of service to producers
therefore you are on time you don't make
waves
you know you you show up you you're
you're a worker among workers
they said you're of service to your
fellow actors which means you don't
steal the show
he gave me this whole list so i show up
and i and the first day i got to this
little tiny script supervisor i wish i
could remember her name
she whispered in my ear she said a
little bird told me you're getting sober
she said i have 35 years you need any
advice or anything you come my way
sit by me i thought wow
i said well i'm supposed to be of
service she goes yeah yeah i know
i know so i was of service for caroline
in the city and i'm telling you it
changed the way i worked today
i don't think about it today but people
use me over and over because
i don't make waves i show up i have my
lines learned
i you know i'm an actor among actors
i don't you know i i do my job and and
directors know that they can
um they can rely on you
they can rely on you that was probably
the biggest gift getting sober gave me
because
you know you don't think like that when
you're you know
so when you're not sober
you